well let's get more on the Iranian story
and find out how the Labour Party think
the government should be reacting
joining us now from Oxbridge in North
London is the shadow justice secretary
richard bergen thank you for being on
the program this morning so morning
Sophie how should the UK government
respond to the news that the Iranians
have seized a UK France tanker well I
think that obviously it's unacceptable
for those vessels to be to be seized and
there should be released but what we
need to avoid am pleased that some
conservative MPs have also spoken out on
this what we need to avoid is a kind of
escalation and being dragged in by
Donald Trump to something which could be
very dangerous indeed so what we really
need to do as a country in the
government is use our diplomatic wait
use under go skating skill really to get
people around the table also get P and
get the United States and get Iran back
into the very important nuclear deal as
well because going away from that risks
things really getting out of control and
I don't think any sensible person wants
that when you mentioned Donald Trump
there do you think we're effectively
being dragged into a conflict that is
really between Iran in the u.s. if we're
not careful then that could be the case
so that's why we need to take a deep
breath that's why we need to use our
diplomatic weight I think we can play a
very positive role in this and it can
play a very positive role
internationally and our role is to speak
up for conflict resolution de-escalation
the nuclear deal descriptions about a
whole range of things but what we don't
want to do is end up being just the
messengers or sidekicks of Donald Trump
and John Bolton I'm encouraged by some
of the things that conservative MPs have
said about this I don't know what the
next prime ministers are going to say
about this not just concerned me greatly
you talk that about Donald Trump we talk
to her about John Bolton and Jeremy
Corbyn tweeted yesterday to say Donald
Trump tearing up the Iran nuclear deal
has fueled confrontation are you not
worried that this just plays and
some people's fears that Labour will
side with people who want our allies
against people who are our allies I mean
Iran has seized a UK tanker head can you
repeat the the last parts of that
question please I couldn't hear that
properly do you do you worry that by
talking about the u.s. in this context
you're playing into people's fears that
the Labour Party will support people who
are not analyzed above our allies such
as the u.s. when Iran and the ones who
seized the UK tanker no no it's not
about that what it's about is trying to
avoid the mistakes of the past people
will remember the great tragedy of Iraq
and I'm really shamed it was a Labour
Prime Minister Tony Blair who sided with
George Bush on that I think Jeremy
Corbyn and others got it correct on that
what we want to ensure doesn't happen is
that the REE that the mistakes of the
past aren't repeated because the
mistakes the past cost many many lives
than mistakes of the past made things
worse and fuelled terrorism and hatred
and that's what we don't want we don't
want to get in situation where things
get out of control
I think we're with the mainstream
opinion on this where we see we don't
want it to ratchet up getting it ending
up getting out of control
ending with military action because if
we did it could be even worse in Iraq
and that doesn't help anybody can you
really compare what's happening now to
Iraq if we end up in a conflict backed
by Donald Trump and I think it would not
only be comparable with Iraq in fact it
could be even worse than Iraq and that
should really scare everybody so we need
sensible negotiations we've got a really
important part to play and diplomatic in
this we can use our negotiating weight I
think that our government has
international respect and our country's
international respect in a way that
Donald Trump doesn't I think we need to
use that for the purposes of conflict
resolution for the purposes of making
sure this doesn't escalate out of
control
okay now you're one Oxbridge you were
campaigning to effectively unseat Boris
Johnson and in favor of the Labour
candidate
called Ally Milani now I just wanted to
ask you about some tweets that the
Labour candidate set sent back in 2012
and 2013 he tweeted that Israel has no
right to exist
he called Piers Morgan a Zionist and he
wrote it will cost you a pound
hashtag Jew why are you supporting
someone who said those things
well quite rightly he's apologized for
those tweets and those tweets that are
disgraceful that he did when he was a
teenager
he's been on a program of learning since
any in fact went to Auschwitz to learn
more about where prejudice comes from
and where prejudice against the Jewish
community can lead so he sent those
messages as tweets as a teenager they
were wrong he's fully apologized for
them and I'm looking forward to
supporting him today because if we're
going to tackle racism we have got to
accept and we've got to push education
for people in our society as a whole
unfortunately there are lots of racist
views held in recent decades our society
is improving that way there's a long way
to go as well so what we can't do is
demonize somebody for unacceptable
disgraceful tweets that as a teenager
what we've got to do is encourage them
to go on an education process and think
again about how the world works how
prejudice works out racism works and
really glad that Allen Milani did that
so comprehensively you know I understand
what you're saying that he sent the
tweets when he was a teenager that he's
tried to reach out to the Jewish
community since but at the same time
when Labour is trying to dampen down
accusation that it is not taking any
Semitism seriously surely you can find
candidates in high profile seats who
haven't made offensive comments about
Jewish people in the past I don't think
you should be prevented from being a
Labour candidate because of tweets that
he's apologized for that he sent when he
was a teenager I'm sure that there's
plenty of things that Boris Johnson did
as a teenager which if you apply that
rule would rule him out from being prime
minister in fact there's plenty of
things that Boris Johnson has said and
written more recently including whilst
he was an MP including while Stu's Mayor
of London including whilst is in the
room to become prime minister which
actually ran
to him unacceptable and unsuitable to
become Prime Minister okay well let's
move on shall we because I want to ask
you about a member of your shadow
justice team Gloria Pierrot who has said
this week that she's not gonna be
standing for the Labour Party at the
next election and she said she quoted a
lack of tolerance for different
viewpoints in the labour party frankly
worries me we have to have respect for
each other even if we disagree because
we're all part of this party does the
lack of Tolerance where are you as well
I'd encourage you are you probably have
that chance I'd encourage you to read
glorious full speech she announced her
decision to her local Labour Party a few
days ago she's going to be standing down
as an MP at the next general election
standing down from the justice team in
her speech which is well worth reading
as part of her you research for this
into your newspapers
oh you've read the speech so what did it
say about so what what did it say about
myself and Jeremy Corbyn and working in
the team together there's an example
what she was talking about how she's
enjoyed working for you and she also
plays Jeremy Corbyn
but she was what I'm asking a bit
specifically is the lack of torrents of
different viewpoints in the labour party
what she said in the speech which you've
obviously read there was a paragraph
where she says in the speech that
Richard she said campaign for Jeremy
Corbyn in the leadership election she
Gloria campaigned for Liz candle in that
leadership election yet we've worked
together really well on important issues
for access to justice and enjoyed it
over the last two years and that's an
example to people in the labour party so
I don't think and I know she feels this
as well by the way
she feels that her speech and her
explanation to her members has been
mischievously misrepresented by the
press and she's tweeted out that about
it herself so don't just take my word
for it see what she's got on Twitter as
well I understand that I mean she also
attend the speech as you say that she's
voted for labour leaders who have never
won from Margaret Beckett all the way
through and to Owen Smith for example
but she also did say
in the speech about the lack of
tolerance for different viewpoints well
a speech sir a long it's interesting the
Orangemen in one particular sentence in
it but what I would say is my focus is
I'm sad that the parliamentary Labour
Party will be used at losing at the next
general election such an effective and
energetic Member of Parliament who
always speaks up for the area that she
represents and I agree I agree as John
MacDonald Jeremy and others have always
agreed the Labour Party is a broad
Church it's a coalition of socialist
Social Democrats trade you NIST's and
other progressives and long may it
continue to be that so I very much agree
that in no political party particularly
political party with over half a million
members do we expect everybody to agree
on every single issue look I campaigned
for Tony Blair I campaigned for Gordon
Brown for Ed Miliband as proud to
campaign for all those lai believes and
of course Jeremy Corbyn so I think we
are a broad church and long may we
remain so